حسنًا، دعونا نتعرف أكثر على الظروف
السائدة داخل قطاع غزة، سأقوم
بإحضار الدكتور غسان أبوس، وهو
جراح بريطاني فلسطيني كان يعمل في
مستشفى الشفاء في مدينة غزة
وكان في موقع مستشفى الحلي.
انفجار المستشفى يوم الأربعاء وإجراء عمليات جراحية لبعض
الضحايا، دكتور جاسان، من الرائع رؤيتك
مرة أخرى ورؤية أنك بخير، فقط
أعطنا فكرة عن كيفية تعامل الجميع في
أعقاب هذا الانفجار، ما نوع
الإصابات التي كنت
تراها؟  فيه شيئين صارا
منذ ذلك
الهجوم الصاروخي أه الأول عدد الجرحى
الذين خرجوا من المستشفى
زاد الضغط على مستشفى الشفاء
الكثير من هؤلاء الجرحى
إصاباتهم خطيرة رجعت أه شاب مصاب
بشظية أه في جسده  رقبته وأمه
وهو الآن في العناية المركزة وكان
هناك العشرات مثله وكان لا بد من
إخلاء المستشفى ح ولذلك تم
إحضار مرضاه إلى مستشفى الشفاء لتلقي
العلاج والآن بعد ذلك  يتركنا في
مستشفى الشفاء بعدد
جرحى يقارب الضعف إن لم يكن أكثر حيث أن هناك
أسرة ويوجد الآن
مرضى ينامون على فرش
في الطوابق ينامون أه في طوابق
أه أه
قسم الطوارئ على العنابر
الوضع من حيث الإفراط، كما تعلمون،
النظام المثقل بالأعباء يسحق
النظام الصحي في غزة وخاصة في
الشفاء، في المرة الأخيرة التي تحدثت فيها أنا وأنت
أخبرتني أن النظام الصحي
بدأ في التفكك، أعني أنك
قلت أنك حصلت على جالونات من الماء.
المطهرات الكيميائية التي كانت تستخدم في السبعينيات
والثمانينيات من القرن الماضي لتعقيم المعدات، كيف يبدو
الوضع الآن، كيف
أقصد كيف تقومون بإجراء
العمليات الجراحية، هل ما زلنا كذلك بالأمس
أخبرنا زملاؤنا في جراحة العظام
أن مستلزماتهم الخارجية قد نفدت
المثبتات وهي الدبابيس والقضبان
اللازمة لتثبيت الكسور
أه في هذه الأنواع من الإصابات
ضغط الماء في المستشفى لم يعد قادرا على
دعم آلة التعقيم أه
كما تحدثنا قبل نفاد ما لدينا
تقريبا  كل شيء اليوم ذهبت عند
الزاوية كان هناك متجر زاوية مفتوح
واشتريت الخل لعلاج بعض
التهابات الجروح أه وكما تعلم
هناك نوع من بكتيريا B
يؤثر على هذه الجروح يسمى pseudomonas
وقد نفدت الحلول لدينا
عالجها وكان العلاج القديم لها هو
الخل، لقد أصبح الأمر كما قلت، أصبح الأمر رهيبًا بشكل
لا يصدق، ما
نسمعه هو نوع من بصيص الأمل فيما
يتعلق بدخول المساعدات، ليس لدينا
فكرة عن موعد ذلك ولكن اه  لكننا
نرى خطوات صغيرة أيها الطبيب، ما الذي
تحتاجه الآن، وما هي الحاجة الأكثر
إلحاحًا، والحاجة
الأكثر إلحاحًا هي كل
ما قد تحتاجه لعلاج 12.5
ألف مريض مصاب بجروح خطيرة يعانون من
أفظع
إصابات الصدمة التي  يمكنك أن تتخيل وكل
ما تحتاجه
لوحدة العناية المركزة كل ما
تحتاجه لغرفة العمليات أه أه
معدات الكسور ضمادات السوائل اذهب
اذهب النظام بأكمله
يتفكك تسونامي هائل
من الجرحى قد طغى على النظام بالكامل
قبل  قبل الحرب كان في غزة ما
مجموعه ألفين ألفين ونصف
ألف سرير، والآن لدينا 12 ألف ونصف
جريح، هل يمكنك أن
تتخيل التناقض بين
القدرة الاستيعابية والطلب في
الوقت الحالي، دكتور غان، شكرًا لك على
الوقت الذي أمضيته في معالجة هذا الأمر.  تحدث إلينا، أعلم مدى
انشغالك بشكل لا يصدق وأشكرك
على كل عملك دكتور غسان هناك
يتحدث إلينا من داخل مدينة غزة
شكرًا لك دكتور